what was it like hearing your dad say to
the grown
kelly
i love you
whoo
it was
hold up
it was um it was necessary it it was
necessary to hear it from my father
you're not gonna get it right every time
and that's okay and i had to give my dad
grace kelly roland opens up about
reconnecting with her estranged father
after having no contact for 30 years my
understanding of where my dad was as a
kid was that he
was not really ready as a father i was
angry at him i was disappointed in him i
had all those feelings of abandonment
while guest hosting today with hoda and
jenna on tuesday the black magic singer
shared the story for the first time and
her father christopher lovett joined her
in the studio come on in christopher
[Music]
[Applause]
as the father and daughter tell it their
story is one of forgiveness i wanted her
to hear the other side of the story
because uh
some of the things that was said it
wasn't true
and some of the things that other people
said it wasn't true there was a
a moment where
i i was like i have to i have to meet
him and i don't want anything to happen
to him and i don't want to have any
regrets
and so the opportunity that we got to
meet each other
that was just a breath so i wanted to
tell kelly i wanted to tell keller that
i loved her and i never have gave her up
but before deciding to reach out kelly
reveals her close friend beyonce's
husband jay-z provided some heartfelt
words of wisdom
what did jay say he said love is all
about risk you got to decide if you're
going to jump you're going to jump yeah
are you going to jump are you going to
jump after three decades christopher
remains apologetic and just wants kelly
to live her best life christopher just
real quick at the end did you ever say
did you ever feel like you had to say
you were sorry oh yes many times yeah
everything
daddy daddy every time every time every
time like every time we're well every
time i have to remind him to call i'm
like daddy call me well i don't know
baby if you're busy
in a separate interview kelly shares how
being a mom influenced their special
reunion it wasn't until
i had
titan
my first
and i said i really need to know
him i want to meet him and by the way
this was after i lost my mother because
i lost my mother three weeks after titan
was born
so
at that time i think i still had these
feelings of like oh my god i have no
parents and it was like no you do you
have one left fast forward to 2022 and
kelly is now a mom of two after
welcoming another son named noah e.t
spoke with the singer shortly after her
baby boy's arrival and gushed over her
former destiny's child bandmates beyonce
and michelle williams meeting her little
man the girls were literally over here
at the house
just
recently
and
when they met the baby
it was like another hard part of my
heart just
you know what i mean like
it's just being able to share
space
with
michelle and b is like
it's truly a gift